[Musique]
c'était jour de fête à boissy un agent
et à la nation avec une fanfare des
flonflons des discours comme pour toutes
les inaugurations
il y avait des ministres des pdg des
directeurs des sous-directeurs bref un
millier de personnalités et le train
bien sûr la vigne de nation à boissy
saint léger qui vient d'être inaugurée
sera ouverte au public dimanche dans
quelques semaines au mois de février
nous ouvrirons la section étoiles
défense ce même réseau régional
deux ans après fin 71 nous viendrons à
l'opéra et peint 71 à 72
on ira jusqu'à saint germain derrière
cette carte la vie de dizaines de
milliers de gens qui va être bouleversée
des habitudes changer comme pour cette
jeune banlieusarde qui a comparé avec
nous les deux voyages l'ancien et le
nouveau je m'appelle parnas je suis
secrétaire bilingue dans une entreprise
installée la nation j'habite
boissy-saint-léger depuis cinq ans tous
les matins je prends le train de 8
heures 26
[Musique]
en scellant
je commence à connaître par coeur ce
chemin avec les réseaux express ça va
changer des choses
pierre ne prendra plus sa voiture il va
être content comme ça je me dis que
c'était vraiment sa session d kimm ans
plein de couleurs et puis même la
musique paris bastille et encore le
métro
au total une bonne heure de transport
pour paula tous les matins et tous les
soirs
voici de nouveau voici le voyage
nouvelle formule maintenant toujours
avec paula
c'est pas mal c'est clair aéré banque
est un peu dur quand même pas de
cendrier
tiens il ne manque qu'une hôtesse comme
dans les avions
tintintin le conducteur du pot est
heureux de vous accueillir à bord du
métro express 2338 nous roulons à la
moyenne
60 km et nous effectuerons le trajet
boissy-saint-léger paris à 22 minutes
[Musique]
la minus nation tout le monde descend
voilà finalement vous avez gagné vous
maintenant 35 minutes le master canton
minutes ce soir donc ça fait une heure
six minutes de plus chez moi
et sur l'année prévoyant le sun 72
heures et 2 minutes de plus chez moi
quatre niveaux mais plus de trente
escalators comme celui là
trois kilomètres de couloirs mais vous
ne les emprunterez pas tous bien entendu
et maintenant c'est ici qu'il fait bon
flâner pratique très pratique
encore plus pratique parce qu
automatique avec des billets magnétique
selon la ratp cent cinquante mille
voyageurs prendront très bientôt le
métro express chauffer au gaz dans
l'année cela fondateur de gagner en tout
pour ces 150 voyageurs que vous passerez
chez vous au lit le matin à l' écoute 24
heures sur la deux le soir
[Musique]